aussi la bateau et un accident et et
forcément il ya accident il y a quelque
chose de terrible est ce un mât qui
s'est abattue ce qui aurait en même
temps arrêté l'émission qui se connaît
depuis d'antenne rien et peut-être aussi
les accus voyez c'est tout enfin il ya
vu pas mal de tempête s'était pas plat
on avait noté un cyclone bon à l'époque
d'ailleurs même le ski se trouvaient au
calme dans l'oeil du cyclone
lui et en plus à côté de la navette est
peut-être sur les bords du cycle aller
prenait davantage de secousses mais il
était habitué à ça n'est ce pas faut pas
oublier qu'il a traversé les
quarantièmes les cinquantièmes
rugissants ou la mère était terrible
parce qu'à faire vous conserver l'espoir
conserve toujours l'espoir à linthal
excellent marin il est résistant malgré
son pied on accuse d'un tas de choses il
est parti en pleine forme confirmé par
le dr babel qu'est l'éminent chirurgien
qui a fait la grève de son pied jusqu'au
départ à la colonne avait pas quelques
appréhensions
absolument pas je n'ai jamais vu aussi
joyeux depuis longtemps il était heureux
de renouer avec son bateau et avec la
mer d'ailleurs comme sa femme a su le
dire tu as failli abeilles avaient déjà
huit jours qu'il était temps mr quand il
est parti on va travailler donc il ya
encore des possibilités de le retrouver
nous espérons qui va selon le terme
employé souvent par son frère qui va
débouler un moment quelconque sur une
côte où vers la guadeloupe ou ailleurs
est ce que la façon dont les recherches
ont été conduites vous en satisfait
écoutez ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils
croyaient devoir faire je ne suis pas
habilité à juger ces gens là les
les gars des avions d atlantic le
bréguet atlantique étaient des gens
consciencieux qui faisait bien leur
boulot
seulement la mère est immense il va
poursuivre ses recherches et ses
recherches sur les lieux est poursuivi
et c'est certainement dans dans ces
derniers jours qu'il aurait dû être au
contraire intensifier ou alien est
stoppée ou tout au moins extrêmement
diminué puisque à l'heure actuelle n'y a
qu'un avion qui part de pointe à pitre
vous savez sur douze heures de vol
quant à jean-françois était dans un de
ses avions sur deux heures de vol il y
avait à peu près trois heures de
recherche d'exploration
le reste c'est l'année et le retour le
rayon d'action été atteint c'est fini
est ce qu'un col avait déjà imaginé
pouvoir se trouvait dans une situation
très difficile en a souvent parlé qu'il
pouvait s'y trouver il se trouvait
d'ailleurs dans des situations nous
avons été pendant le tour du monde par
le cap horn
trois semaines sans avoir aucune
nouvelle est vraiment nous n'étions pas
inquiet on savait qu avant sa radio de
flancher où tous ont échoué sur le
compte de la radio
d'ailleurs c'est exact parce que l'un
dimanche je fais déjà dit enfin vous
voulez que nous allions faire une visite
sortir quoi fini nous chantons elle
avait appelé une demi heure après on
nous appelait j'ai rétabli le contact la
radio fonctionne je suis heureux je suis
à bord voilà envoyé trois semaines après
et là une radio du tout c'est ça qui
nous inquiète